la petite soeur de toute petite soeur je
te présente bérengère m'a trop jeunes
fiancés
j'étais il ya un rôle dans sa chambre au
sais pas si nous reconnaît mais si tu
vas aller le voir
mais un espoir de guérison non
je tente avec ce resto de continuer dans
l'esprit de papa avec des petits prix
pour les gens qui ont peu d'argent mais
ray j'arrive au plus c'était génial
qu'on a tous je me fais que les recettes
de notre père les recettes de notre père
qui avait piqué notre mère il savait pas
faire cuire un oeuf avant qu'elle meure
[Musique]
comment tu as fait bosser sur wendel ont
signalé que je ne sois pas c'est un
accident qui nous a traités qu'on écoute
tu sais même pas ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
on a retrouvé les restes d'un bateau
probablement d'émigrants fait attention
et peuvent être dangereux dangereux
[Musique]
c'est horrible tous ces bons souvenirs à
11 elle mangeait le guen
et que ça
non j'avais 20 ans veut aussi je sais
pas non pas encore parvenu à trouver la
colline gmat des rescapés du bateau
qu'est ce qu'on fait
washington le site
[Musique]
b